madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
football donc à la une avec ce match
france bulgarie qui a fait vibrer les
coeurs d'abord au parc des princes où se
déroulait cette rencontre et puis aussi
devant les écrans de télévision puisque
nous retransmettons le match en direct
trêve de suspense si vous n'avez pas
suivi le match france bulgarie la france
ira en argentine je vous le dis tout de
suite les footballeurs français ont
battu les bulls gar par 3 buts à 1 après
avoir vers leurs pertes dominé
pratiquement la rencontre de bout en
bout depuis l'iran 10e on peut dire que
les français ont fait exactement le
match que l'on attendait d'eux ils ne se
sont pas énervés en première mi-temps
religieuses ont très très bien joué il
avait un public et tout acquis à leur
cause ils ont fait un match plein face à
une équipe bulgare qui a un peu déçu
mais on savait que cette équipe bulgare
était la plus faible du groupe dans
lequel se trouvait la france avec
l'irlande donc les bulgares qui a eu la
chance d'avoir un bon arbitrage pour eux
face aux français face aux irlandais qui
ont tenu jusqu'au premier but de
rocheteau qui après sont écroulés donc
les français ont en argentine ce sera
leur septième participation à la coupe
du monde et l on peut dire que tout le
football français se réjouit du succès
des zones du belgo qui ont fait un très
beau match il ya des talents dans cette
équipe de france on peut espérer en tout
cas que les français en argentine
réussiront une bonne coupe du monde
quand on connaîtra peut-être leurs
grands rivaux 58,9 me rasseoir ne rêvons
pas tout car les adversaires des groupes
de la france seront connus le 14 janvier
puisque le tirage au sort de la coupe du
monde aura lieu à buenos aires séjour le
voilà pour ces précisions vers l'art je
suppose qu'on va revoir quelques
quelques images de ce match quelques
images de ce match et
une ambiance assez extraordinaire dans
le parc des princes on peut dire que
depuis que le parc des princes était
construire ne vais pas senti une telle
ambiance
40000 spectateurs quand vous voudrez mon
cher lambert pour les images de cette
rencontre
voilà les français sont naturellement en
bleu et ils vont en attaque et donc en
posant leur jeu en jouant très très bien
en faisant circuler la balle et vont
obtenir le premier but à la 38e minute
vous voyez que les actions françaises
sont très très bonne très dangereusement
toujours un petit peu quelque chose une
fois sur la commune faute sur platini
que les arbitres ne pas souffrir sur
corner que n'a pas fait un arbitrage à
la maison elle l'est sur ce corner
suivez bien ce ballon tiré par 6 13
heures est venu prêter main forte à ses
attaquants le ballon lui revient
finalement c'est aux chevaux qui
doperait marque ce premier but le but de
la qualification le but de la délivrance
aussi pour cette équipe de france voyez
la joie les tricolores encore une fois
qu'ils ne se sont pas énervés ils ont
marqué à 7 africaine minutes ils ont
toujours très bien joué en ce début de
match et là c'est vraiment le but on
peut dire de la libération
lyon se du sous un autre angle toujours
donc tiré par didier six marius trésor
qui saute plus haut que tout le monde
le ballon est cafouillé hausse nos
voisins un grand beau but mais j c c'est
un but quand même et rocheteau qui bat
de très près les français vont continuer
à jouer il ya bien joué en année par
guillou très très beau par un excellent
la con des plis par naturellement michel
platini qui va placer un tir regardez
bien la dernière minute de la première
mi-temps bras neuf et sauvé par sa barre
transversale
un parc des princes donc chauffé à blanc
qui encourage son équipe et qui voit
donc cette équipe de france mené un but
à zéro et là la barre souvent corogne 5
0 pour l'équipe de france en deuxième mi
temps les français savent qu'il faut
absolument continuer à attaquer parce
qu'un but on ne sait jamais les bulgares
peuvent également en marquant et en cas
d'égalité ce serait eux qui seraient
qualifiés regardez bien ce tir de
platini
on va mieux le voir du reste de doux
ralenti mais là c'est le billet aller
retour pour l'argentine que vient de
signer lui celle papini par ce tir de 25
mètres environ tous les français le
savent les joueurs
les spectateurs et téléspectateurs où
tout le monde est content et revoyons ce
tir de platini d'abord le ballon pour
bossis donc paix qui donne un fixe fixed
toujours de son pied gauche 6 qui aurait
eu deux occasions de but dans cette
rencontre qui n'aura pas marqué mais qui
donne ici un bon ballon à platini
complètement démarqué à 25 mètres du but
un tir du cayrol garder la trajectoire
du ballon
goranov a été surpris ne plus rien faire
cette fois la barre ne vient pas le
secours et 2 0 les français sont presque
en démonstration ils vont se relâcher un
peu
et à quatre minutes de la fin les
bulgares vont marquer un but
rennes n'a rien pu faire ils ont marqué
un but ouvert mais n'a donc à 2 1 il
reste quatre minutes à jouer et le
système français 20 jours ci les
bulgares réussissent égalisation ceux
qui vont en argentine les le système se
disant ne vous suit va pas durer
longtemps
les français vont quelque peu s'énerver
et vont bénéficier d'un contre favorable
car les bulgares étaient venus pour
défendre ne sapera tellement attaqué ils
vont se faire surprendre alors qu'ils
sont complètement dégarni leurs dépenses
lundvall the uk dégager n'importe
comment la pompe se précipite et lacombe
a joué très intelligemment regarder la
tirah les penseurs trouve d'alger qui
rentrent à la place de rocheteau un
contre favorable port d'alger
bellevue cette fois la france est
qualifiée et bien qualifié la suite d'un
fait c'est très bon encore une fois
beaucoup de talent beaucoup
d'intelligence dans le jeu des français
ce soir face à la bulgare nous allons
revoir ce but au ralenti donc avec ce
très bon débordement des 2 lacombe et le
centre sur d'alger il a donc marqué le
troisième but de la victoire 3-1 ou du
chlore qui réjouit tout le monde
les milieux du football en tout cas et
thierry roland a pu s'entretenir la
suite de cette rencontre avec michel
platini alors qu'ida lbo porté par ses
joueurs
pleure de joie les nerfs ont lâché
mais la france est qualifiée
via michel platini voilà une bonne chose
de faite aux lyonnais qualifier c'était
très difficile
salle hurle méritée sur l'ensemble du
tournoi en bulgarie déjà les gens on
était passé à côté d'un grand exploit
mais vous savez en football il suffit
pas démérité faut concrétiser c'est le
plus difficile lorsque après avoir
dominé tout le match comme vous l'avez
fait avec vos camarades de l'équipe de
france 2 0 s'est passé à 2 1 quelle a
été votre état d'esprit sur le terrain
nous on a toujours été serein vaumas été
difficile vous savez eux n'ont eux ne
croyait pas tellement de 1 peut-être
d'ici on a l'impression qu'ils se
croyaient mais ils n'y croyaient plus et
vous savez beaucoup de choses qui
passent dans la tête et notamment six as
et marca mais ça m'a rappelé ma chère
francisco savent à qui on a fait deux
ici au parc des princes mon premier
match à juillan pas recommencer parce
qu'on le tient ses billets et pour vous
travaillez vous aviez la sensation
d'être déjà à buenos aires et de revenir
à roissy et donne et élever nos dires
mais messi marquait mais tard voici
exactement
michel maintenant que l'équipe de france
a fait le plus dur c'est à dire se
qualifier je pense que l'équipe de
france telle qu'on l'a vu en cette
soirée du parc des princes que personne
n'oubliera c'est une équipe capable je
le crois de faire quelque chose en
argentine et oui maintenant elle match
est terminé on attendait le match là et
vous savez que le football professionnel
est très difficile parce qu'on attend
toujours au footballeur qu'il se
surpasse et
on attendra beaucoup de l'équipe de
france en argentine mais là si on finit
si on gagne pas la finale ça sera pas un
problème il faudra bien se placer et
notamment participé au deuxième tour et
le président de la république n'a pas
tardé à envoyer ses félicitations à
l'équipe de france ses félicitations
aussi ses voeux pour la suite de la
participation de l'équipe de france à
cette grande compétition internationale
qui est donc la coupe du monde de
football qui aura lieu en juin prochain
en argentine
l'autre information